[موسيقى]
لا تتوقف ماسي المهاجرين وطالبي اللجوء في
البحر الابيض المتوسط ومع ذلك لا يتردد
هؤلاء في ركوب امواج البحر املا في حياه
افضل لكن ماساه غرقي مركب قباله سواحل
اليونان وهي الثانيه خلال شهر قد تكون
بالنسبه الى بعض المسؤولين الاوروبيين
دليلا اخرا على صحه مواقفهم السياسيه
الداعيه الى وقف الهجره غير النظاميه الى
دولي بهذا السياق كثف المسؤولون
الاوروبيون زيارتهم الى تونس خلال الايام
الماضيه سعيا لاقناعها او حتى اغراءها
بالدعم المالي والاقتصادي من اجل بذل جهد
اكبر في صد طالبي اللجوء والمهاجرين
القادمين من سواحلها فقد اعلنت رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه عن مساعدات ماليه
لانعاش الاقتصاد التونسي وتعزيز الشراكه
مع تونس في اطار ما سمي بحزمه الشراكه
الشامله والتي من المنتظر ان يتم اعتمادها
من قبل الجانبين قبل نهايه الشهر الحالي
فما هي طبيعه هذه الشراكه التي يسعى اليها
الاتحاد الاوروبي مع تونس في مجال مكافحه
الهجره وكيف تبدو المقاربه الاوروبيه
لازمه الهجره واللجوء بضوء الخلافات
المستمره بين دول الاتحاد حول الطريقه
الامثل لادارتها اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه
من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اثارت زياره الوفد الاوروبيه
الاخيره الى تونس الكثير من التساؤلات حول
الدوري المطلوب من تونس في مكافحه ما يسمى
الهجره غير النظاميه التي تؤرق المسؤولين
الاوروبيين الذين يستعدون لمناقشه اصلاح
نظام الهجره داخل البرلمان الاوروبي
والتصديق عليه قبل الشروع في تطبيقه عن
التحديات التي يطرحها ملف الهجره بالنسبه
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وتفاصيل الاتفاق
الجديد الذي يربط الدعم المالي الاوروبي
لتونس بتعاونها في هذا المجال يسعدنا ان
يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه من بروكسل
كبير الباحثين في مركز مارتنز للدراسات
الاوروبيه من تونس نسرين بن بلقاسم
الباحثه في علم الاجتماع والمختصه في
قضايا الهجره ومن روما الصحفي صالح
المثنائي فاهلا بهم جميعا
بينما يحتدم الجدل داخل الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي حول السبيل الامثل للتعاطي مع
ملف الهجره تتواصل الماساه الانسانيه
لطالبي اللجوء تلاقي 79 منهم حتفهم اثر
غرق مركبهم قباله السواحل اليونانيه وقد
انقذ خبر السواحل مئه واربعه اشخاص في
عمليه وصفها بانها واحده من اكبر عمليات
البحث على الاطلاق في المتوسط واشارت
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التابعه للامم
المتحده الى ان حدث الغرق واحد من اكبر
الماسي في البحر المتوسط مشيره الى وجود
ما يصل الى 400 شخص على متن القارب الغارق
في حين قالت جمعيه حقوقيه اوروبيه انها
تلقت من القارب نداء استغاثه تحدث عن وجود
ما لا يقل عن 750 شخصا على متنه
ومنذ بدايه العام الجاري غرق 44 شخصا في
شرق البحر الابيض المتوسط وذلك وفق
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره بينما كان العام
الماضي هو العام الاكثر ماساويه بالنسبه
الى المهاجرين وطالبي اللجوء القادمين من
بلدان في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا
سجلت المنظمه الدوليه للهجره ما يقرب من
3800 حاله وفاه بين المهاجرين العام
الماضي اي بزياده 11% عن العام الذي سبقه
وهي اعلى حصيله منذ 2017 وفقا للتقرير
الجديد الصادر عن المنظمه في الثالثه عشر
من هذا الشهر
وبينت المنظمه ان الموت غرقا في البحر
بصوره عامه والسبب الاكثر شيوعا لوفاه
المهاجرين غير النظاميين اما على الطرق
البريه فقد اشارت المنظمه الى ان اكبر عدد
من الوفيات في شمال افريقيا سجل في ليبيا
حيث لقي 117 مهاجرا حتفهم وفي منطقه الشرق
الاوسط توفي
825 شخصا معظمهم في اليمن
واوضحت المنظمه ان ندره البيانات الرسميه
تشير الى ان العدد الفعلي للوفيات على طرق
الهجره داخل منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا من المرجح ان يكون اعلى بكثير مما
تم الاعلان عنه
وقالت المنظمه الدوليه للهجره ان هذا
العدد المثير للقلق من الوفيات يتطلب
اهتماما عاجلا وجهودا متضافره لتعزيز
سلامه وحمايه المهاجرين
وقد شهد الثلث الاول من هذا العام زياده
كبيره في اعداد المهاجرين وطالبي اللجوء
في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي التي تقول انها
تواجه تحديات غير مسبوقه على حدودها
الخارجيه وتخشى من تواصل تدفق المهاجرين
وزياده اعدادهم خلال السنوات المقبله
سجلت وكاله حمايه الحدود التابعه للاتحاد
الاوروبي فرونتكس زياده في عدد المهاجرين
غير النظاميين مقدارها 30% خلال الثلث
الاول من هذا العام مقارنه بالفتره نفسها
من العام الماضي وهي النسبه الاعلى منذ
سبع سنوات فقد دخل خلال هذه الفتره نحو 81
الف مهاجر غير نظامي الى دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي منهم نحو 54 الف مهاجر وصلوا الى
سواحل ايطاليا منذ بدايه العام الجاري حسب
بيانات وزاره الداخليه الايطاليه
ووفقا للمفوضيه الامم المتحده الساميه
لشؤون اللاجئين فان معظم المهاجرين الذين
تم تسجيلهم مؤخرا في ايطاليا جاءوا من
تونس
وكان التقرير سنوي لوكاله فرونتكس كشف عن
حوالي 330 الف حاله عبور غير نظامي جرت
عبر الحدود الخارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي في
وذكرت الوكاله ان الاعداد بلغت اعلى مستوى
منذ عام 2016 بزياده بلغت نحو 64% اكثر
مما كانت عليه عام 2021
وبالنسبه للجنسيات شكل السوريون والافغان
والتونسيون نحو 47% من هذه الحالات
وتضاعف عدد السوريين تقريبا خلال هذا
العام عن سابقه ليصل الى 94000 شكلت
النساء عشره في المئه منهم بينما بلغت
نسبه الاطفال نحو تسعه في المئه وكانت
اوروبا استقبلت في عام 2015 وحده اكثر من
مليون لاجئ ما دفع المفوضيه الى تسميته
عام ازمه اللاجئين في اوروبا وللحد من
تدفق المهاجرين واللاجئين يشارك اكثر من
2400 رجل امن من وكاله فرونتكس في عمليات
حما يه الحدود الخارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
اضافه الى دعم الدول المجاوره في الضفه
الجنوبيه للبحر المتوسط
[موسيقى]
هذه سبيل عشرات الالاف من العابرين الى
الضفه الشماليه للبحر الابيض المتوسط رغم
كل الماسي التي شهدتها مياهه لا تتوقف
مغامرات الهجره غير النظاميه انطلاقا من
سواحل شمال افريقيا
هنا من تونس ينطلق اغلبهم باتجاه اقرب
نقطه اوروبيه وهي ايطاليا تتيح لهم
المسافه البحريه بين مدينه صفاقس وجزيره
لامبيدوزا الايطاليه فرصه الوصول الى
التراب الاوروبي في فتره اقصر واضافه الى
صفاقس تنطلق قوارب الهجره غير النظاميه من
اماكن اخرى على طول الشواطئ التونسيه من
جرجيس وبوغرارا وصولا الى المنستير وبنزرت
شمالا
هذا ما يفسر حاله الاستنفار التي تقودها
رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا جورجيا ميلوني لحشد
تاييد اوروبي للتوصل الى اتفاق مع تونس
بشان كبح جماح الارقام المتصاعده للهجره
غير النظاميه فقد اجرت برفقه رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئيس وزرائه هولندا
محادثات مع السلطات التونسيه اعقبها اعلان
دعم اوروبي فوري لتونس بقيمه 150 مليون
يورو منها 100 مليون يورو توجهوا لاداره
الحدود ومكافحه الشبكات التهريب البشر
وبينما ترزح تونس تحت ازمه ماليه بسبب
تعثر مفاوضاتها مع صندوق النقد الدولي
للحصول على قرض جديد وعدت رئيسه وزراء
ايطاليا بدعم تونس في مفاوضاتها مع
الصندوق
خفضت وكاله فيتش تصنيف تونس الائتمانيه
الى مستوى سي سي سالب ما يعني امكانيه
التخلف عن السداد يؤكد ذلك انها احوج ما
تكون لضخ اموال في اقتصادها المنهك لكن ما
يقترح الاوروبيون عليها ينطوي على محاذيره
تتعلق بحقوق الانسان فقد انتقد المنتدى
التونسي للحقوق الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
هذا السخاء الاوروبي لانه يخفي حسب
المنتدى ابتزازا يقوم على مقايضه
المساعدات الاقتصاديه بلعب دور شرطي
الحدود كل ذلك سبقه الرئيس قيس سعيد
بزياره مفاجئه الى صفاقس سبقت وصول الوفد
الاوروبي وقف خلالها عند نقطه تجمع
للرعايه الافارقه وقال ان بلاده لن تقبل
ان تكون حارس حدود لدول اخرى وان الحل لن
يكون على حساب تونس
نرحب بضيوفنا من جديد ونبدا بالسيد فيت
نوفوتني في بروكسل
هل هناك تصور واضح اوروبي بالضبط
عن المطلوب من تونس في قضيه الهجره
شكرا
لا اعرف تفاصيل
المفاوضات مؤخرا بين المفوضيه الاوروبيه
والسيده
والرئيس التونسي ولكن ما اعرفه هو
انه مناقش عده امور احدها
ايقاف
الانتقال المنتظم من تونسيه من تونس الى
اوروبا
واستعاده المواطنين
الذين ليس لهم حقا يبقوا الاتحاد الاوروبي
وايضا اعاده الاشخاص الذين
لكن تونس تقع على الطريق الى اوروبا
وايضا طلب المزيد من الجهود لاعاده اولئك
الذين جاؤوا الى تونس من دول اخرى خاصه من
الدول الافريقيه في التعديلات الاخيره على
نظام الهجره واللجوء الاوروبي وقع الحديث
عن اعاده المهاجرين غير النظاميين الى
الدول التي انطلقوا منها اخر مره ليست
بالضروره الدول الاصليه بمعنى ان الكل
ستتم اعادتهم الى تونس هل هذا فعلا هو
الوضع بشكل واضح
بالتاكيد هذا كلام غير صحيح في الاتحاد
الاوروبي
يردوا اعاده الاشخاص الذين البقاء على
الارض الاوروبيه او الذين كانوا هناك منذ
سنوات وعقود الان التركيز هو على تونس لان
الكثير من الحالات الوصول غير النظاميه
للاتحاد الاوروبي مصدرها تونس ولذلك لابد
من دراسه اعاده هؤلاء
الترحيلهم الى تونس
وفي حاله اذا لا يمكن
يحق لهم حصول على اللجوء والاتحاد
الاوروبي يحاول اعاده الناس من اينما
جاؤوا اذا لم يستطيعوا البقاء
افريقيا واسيا وليس الى امريكا وليس الى
الولايات المتحده
بالنسبه لتونس سيده نسرين بالقاسم تصريحات
الرئيس قيس سعيد واضحه انه ليس مستعدا ان
يلعب دور حارس الحدود
وكثيرا ما انتقد المقاربه الاوروبيه
لموضوع الهجره غير النظاميه اذا في هذه
الحاله لماذا كل هذه التخوفات داخل
المنظمات التونسيه من هذه المساله
والعلاقه مع اوروبا
صحيح ان الهجره غني باميه اخذت منحه
تصاعدي في تونس ولكن الاشكاليه ان تونس
اصبحت منطقه عبور والقوارب تضم العديد من
الجنسيات الغير التونسيين ولكن لا يجب على
الدول الاوروبيه ان تستغل الوضع الاقتصادي
الصعب في تونس وتقوم
باقتراح مبالغ ماليه من اجل تحسين الوضع
الاقتصادي من اجل غايات اخرى
لتدعم مصلحتها الخاصه فلا يجب ان تكون
تونس هي الدوله الوحيده التي تتحمل
مسؤوليه المهاجرين الغير نظامين لانها
اصبحت الهجره تضم العديد من الجنسيات وليس
التونسيين فقط
احد القيادات المعارضه في تونس
بن بلقاسم قال قال يفترض ان تكون محادثات
تونس هي مع ليبيا مع الجزائر مع هذه الدول
التي ياتي منها
اللاجئون من جنوب الصحراء وليس مع اوروبا
هل تعتقد ان تعتقدين ان تونس ربما ايضا
اخطات بين قوسين في التركيز في محادثات
الهجره مع اوروبا تحديدا
هو من المفروض ان تكون هي مسؤوليه مشتركه
بين جميع الدول التي
فيها نسبه مرتفعه من المهاجرين غير
النظاميين حتى بالنسبه للدول الاوروبيه لا
يجب ان تتفاوض فقط مع الدوله التونسيه
وتجعلها حارسه للحدود وتحملها مسؤوليه
المهاجرين غير النظاميين فهي مسؤوليه
مشتركه ما بين سياسات جميع الدول ليست
تونس ليست حكرا على تونس فقط
عندما نتحدث عن عن اوروبا السيد صالح
المثناني نتحدث بشكل خاص عن ايطاليا
ايطاليا بدت مع ميلوني في الاشهر الماضيه
ومع وزير الخارجيه ايضا وكانها الدوله
الاكثر حماسه لموضوع مقاومه الهجره غير
النظاميه والاكثر ايضا حماسه للتعاون مع
تونس ومساعدتها
ما الخلفيه من وراء كل ذلك
بدايه لابد ان نضع يعني زياره رئيس
الوزراء الايطاليه
جورج ميلوني يوم 6 جوان كانت زياره خاطفه
تلتها زيارتها مع الوفد الاوروبي في
سياقها اي ان ايطاليا منذ سنوات حاولت ان
تكون لها مقاربات عده لمكافحه الهجره
الغير نظاميه من بين مقاربه امنيه مساعده
يعني البلدان مثل ليبيا وتونس
وتمكينها من قوارب
لمكافحه هذه الهجره
النظاميه وحاولت ايضا ان تقنع بقيه
شركائها الاوروبيين
بان تحترم ما كان ينص عليه اتفاق دبلن او
ما يسمى بلائحه دبلن ثلاثه وهي
ان
تاخذ هذه البلدان شيئا الذي تواجهه
ايطاليا نحن نعلم ان ايطاليا هي البلد
اوروبي الذي يصل اليه اكثر عدد من
المهاجرين مثل ما ذكر التقرير منذ قليل
اكثر من خمسين الف بدايه من سنه 2023 ولكن
المفارقه ان عدد التونسيين لا يتجاوز
34400 400 شخص اي ان معدل سبعه بالمئه
كانت هناك في السنوات الماضيه اتفاقيات
بين تونس
وايطاليا لترحيل هؤلاء التونسيين بطبيعه
الحال كان عدد منهم يتمكن من البقاء في
ايطاليا ثم يذهب الى بلدان اخرى ويستقر
ويتمكن حتى في بعض الاحيان من الحصول على
وثائق يعني اقامه اليوم
ما يحدث في ايطاليا وعدد المهاجرين الذين
يصلون الى ايطاليا هو عدد مهول ومعظمهم من
بلدان
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
مع هذه الحكومه الحل ارتاته رئيس الوزراء
هو في اقناع بقيه الشركاء الاوروبيين يعني
27 دوله من الاتحاد الاوروبي ان تكون هناك
اتفاقيات هذه المره بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
ككل وبين تونس كانت هناك سياسه من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي تعتمد على استقبال
المهاجرين وطالب اللجوء اليوم الاتفاق او
محتواه
صدر بعد لقاء وزراء داخليه يوم 8 جوان
الماضي هو التضامن ليس لاستقبال المهاجرين
ومن
يصلون في قوارب الموت ولكن في ترحيلهم
وبالتالي
تحاول يعني ايطاليا وبقيه الشركاء
الاوروبيين ان يستغلوا هذه
الفتره التي تعيشها تونس من ازمه اقتصاديه
خانقه ومحاوله يعني اقناعها
بان تقبل بترحيلهم الشيء المهم هنا هو ان
هذه لا تعد ان تكون سواء يعني اتفاق نوايا
ولا بد من الانتظار اخر الشهر لنرى اذا
كانت تونس ستوقع على هذا يعني
هذه الوثيقه ام لا وحتى بعد اذنك
طالما هي اتفاق نوايا مبدئيا مثل ما ذكرت
هل هناك وهنا نسال سيد
ضيفنا من بروكسيل سيد نوفوتني عما اذا كان
هناك مبدئيا جماعه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
على هذه المقاربه الايطاليه مقاربه
الايطاليه اقول الايطاليه لانها هي الاكثر
حماسه وتريد كانها تريد ان تقايض
المساعدات الماليه الى تونس وان تريد ان
تقايض دعم تونس مع صندوق النقد الدولي
بالتجاوب مع المطالب الاوروبيه في قضايا
الهجره كيف هي المقاربه الاوروبيه لهذا
الموضوع
ان فعلا ايطالي هي التي تعلق الرياده
وقياده هذه العمليه في التفاوض مع تونس
والدول واعضاء الاتحاد الاوروبي الاخرين
يتفقون مع المقاربه الايطاليه من حيث
المبدا وصحيح القول ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعرض دعما ماليا كبيرا لتونس
لكن تحت الشروط قاسيه ومحدده
وايضا
التقديم مساعدات لاداره موضوع الهجره هذا
صحيح المساعدات الاوروبيه القصد منها
مساعدات ماليه الغرض منها ان تكون وسيله
مساعده
لتشجيع الحكومه التونسيه القيام
بالاصلاحات الضروريه في البلاد
اصلاح النظام
والمساعدات ودعم المالي وما الى ذلك من
انظمه اخرى
وبالتالي
فان اهتمام
اتحاد الاوروبي ان تصبح تونس بلدا اكثر
استقرارا لا يود الناس ان يغادروها او
يهربوا منها ولكن سيد نفوتني عندما نرى
تعليق بعض الاعلام الاوروبي نجده ينظر
بكثير من الريبه لهذا التواصل الاوروبي مع
تونس يعني مثلا
مجله نوفالو سلفاتور الفرنسيه تتحدث عن
خطوره ما سمته خاطئ ممكن بين ميلوني وقيس
سعيد صحيفه ليمون تتحدث بان الاهتمام
الاوروبي
يعود الى الخوف من تاثير الوضع الاقتصادي
المتردي في تونس على امن اوروبا في تايم
تتحدث عن ان
المساعدات الى تونس تتطلب
موافقات بقيه الحكومات الغربيه وهذا
الاوروبيه وهذا ايضا غير مضمون اذا ما
مصير هذه الاتصالات مع تونس
املوا
املوا بان اي صفقه اذا ما وقعت بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتونس تكون لصالح
الطرفين
وبالتالي انا لست واثقا بالتاكيد ما هو
البديل لمثل هذه الصفقه
اعتقد الاتحاد الاوروبي يهتموا بشكل كبير
في تقليل عدد
المهاجرين غير النظاميين الذين
يستقلون السفن غير صالحه للابحار للوصول
الى ارضى
تصبح اوروبا هي مسؤوله عن انقاذهم
وايصالهم الى البر ورعايتهم وفي كثير من
حالاتهم لا يحق لهم اللجوء وليس لديهم حق
اللجوء واعتقد انهم وبالتالي اعتقد ان هذه
مساعده الماليه مفيده لتونس لتقوم
الاصلاحات واعمل للتالي ان تكون هذا
الاتفاق يكون مفيدا للطرفين فائده متبادله
ساخذ كلمه صفقه التي استعملتها سيد نفوت
اسال عنها السيده نسرين بالبلقاسم
نائب سابق تونسي في البرلمان مسجد كرباعي
الشار الى ما سماه صفقه المتوسط
شبهها حتى بصفقه القرن لانه يعترض عليها
والمنظمات التونسيه المهتمه بالهجره تحدثت
عن ان المساعدات الاوروبيه هي مجرد طعم
لتونس او فخ لتونس وهناك من تحدث عن
ابتزاز لتونس واستغلال هشاشتها الماليه
والاقتصاديه لماذا كل هذه التخوفات في حين
ان تونس لم تعطي بعد موافقتها وهناك
بالعكس تصريحات من قيس سعيد مره اخرى
اقولها معارضه لهذا التوجه الاوروبي
هو بالنسبه للدول الاوروبيه فهي غايتها
وهدفها الوحيد هو الحد من عدد المهاجرين
غير النظاميين وتريد استعمال جميع الطرق
للحد من هذه الظاهره والخوف دائما يكون من
موجود من ممارسه ضغوطات مثلا على الرئيس
التونسي من اجل الاتفاق او التوقيع على
الاتفاقيات التي تكون فيها شروط التي
ترجع بالضرر الى الدوله التونسيه لذلك
دائما يجب على جميع المنظمات التي تهتم
بمساله الهجره ان تكون يقظ وتتابع دائما
موضوع الهجره الغير نظاميه لكي لا نقع في
هذا الفخ الذي يمكن ان يجعل من الدوله
التونسيه يرجع عليها بالضرر الكثير بسبب
هذه المفاوضات او الاتفاقيات التي يمكن ان
توقعها مع الدول الاوروبيه عموما او
ايطاليا تحديدا الملفت
ليس فقط المعارضين هم الذين اعربوا عن هذا
التوجس حتى بعض المؤيدين الرئيس قيس سعيد
بعثوا اليه برساله يطلبون منها عدم الخضوع
لهذا الابتزاز الاوروبي كما وصفوه من
بينما قالوه مثلا تجوع الحره ولا تقبل ان
تتحول الى حارس لاوروبا هل تعتقدين بان
فعلا هناك اجماع في تونس على رفض ما تريده
اوروبا من تونس
[موسيقى]
على الرفض ان تكون تونس حارسه للحدود
البحريه او تحملها مسؤوليه المهاجرين غير
النظاميين كما ذكرت سابقا انها هي هجره
تمس الكثير من الدول والجنسيات نجدهم
موجودين في القوارب الهجره النظاميه
وهؤلاء المهاجرين كذلك يتحملون مسؤوليه
حريه التنقل ويجدون انفسهم ضحايا في البحر
الابيض المتوسط لذلك يجب ان تكون تونس
منتبهه جدا ورغم اننا نمر
بمشاكل اقتصاديه او عدم استقرار سياسي في
بعض الاحيان في تونس ولكن لا يجب ان نقع
في هذا ربما الفخ او الابتزاز الذي تقوم
به الدول الاوروبيه من اجل مصلحتها الخاصه
او الحد من هذه الظاهره لكن يجب ان تتضافر
الجهود وان تكون هي ليست اشكاليه تمس
الدوله التونسيه فقط او مشكله تخص الدوله
التونسيه فقط ولكن هي
مسؤوليه الكثير من الدول ويجب ان تتغير
سياسات الهجره وتكون محترمه اكثر لحقوق
الانسان ليس سرا سيد صالح المثناني ان
ايطاليا وميلوني ووزير خارجيتها ومن اكثر
حماسه في هذا الاتجاه حتى عندما زاروا
تونس مع المفوضه الاوروبيه ومع رئيس
الوزراء الهولندي رئيس الوزراء الهولندي
ايضا توجهه يميني هل هل هذا التوجه
الايطالي اليميني قادر على ان يستقطب
المزيد من المؤيدين الاوروبيين لصفقه ما
مع تونس بالمواصفات التي تريدها ايطاليا
يعني هذا ما تحاول ان تقوم به ايطاليا
يعني
رئيس الوزراء الايطاليه
قالت اكثر من مره انها تمكنت من اقناع
بقيه الاطراف حتى ان يعني لم تستطع صراحه
ان تقنعهم لابد من الاشاره الى ان هناك
بلدين وهما تشيكا وبولندا التي امتنعت عن
التصويت وهناك اربع بلدان اخرى من بينها
امتنعت في حين ان بولندا عفوا وتشيكيا
صوتت ضد يعني هي تحاول نحن نعلم ان
ايطاليا وبقيه البلدان الاوروبيه والتي
يعني فيها تصاعد لليمين المتطرف تنظر الى
مصالحها ولكن يعني ما هذا هذا يعني ما
تحاول ان تقوم بايطاليا وبقيه البلدان
الاوروبيه هو النظر الى مصلحته والحد من
الهجره الغير نظاميه ما قدمته ايطاليا في
زيارتها الاخيره مع الوفد الاوروبي هي لا
تعدو ان تكون وعود ولا بد من يعني الرجوع
الى الوراء نحن نعلم ان بعض الثوره بعد
2011 كم من بلد اوروبي وعد تونس بدعم
وباموال طائله وبلدان شقيقه وصديقه ايضا
وعدت تونس
بضخ المزيد من مساعده الماليه ولكن لم تصل
هذه المساعدات الماليه واظن ان السلطه
التونسيه فهمت هذا
وبالاضافه الى هذا الملف الحارق وهو ملف
الهجره هناك ايضا ملف حارق اخر وهو ملف
المفاوضات مع صندوق النقد الدولي واظن ان
السلطه اليوم فهمت ان ايذاء صارت في هذا
المسار فستكون هناك وهذا ما قاله الرئيس
قيس سعيد ستكون هناك ازمه وربما هذا سيدفع
بانفجار اجتماعي
وبطبيعه الحال س له ارتدادات ليس فقط في
الداخل ولكن في البلدان التي المجاوره
لتونس وحتى في اوروبا هناك نقطه قبل قليل
ضيفنا من بروكسيل سيد صالح المثناني قال
غير صحيح نريد ان استوضح منها معك هل الان
واضحه هذه القصه ايطاليا تدفع بعد الاتفاق
مع الدول الاوروبيه ويبدو ان هذا ما حصل
وعلى الاقل ما يروج انه حسن
في عند الامساك ببعض المهاجرين غير
النظاميين سيتم قدمه من تونس سيتم ارجاعهم
الى تونس سواء هذا جاء من جنوب الصحراء او
جاء من ليبيا او جاء من الجزائر او جاء من
اي مكان هل هذه النقطه فعلا محسومه
اوروبيه نقصد
ساستعير ساستعير نفس الكلمه التي استعرتها
من ضيفك في بروكسال هذه الصفقه يعني
محتواها هو ان تقبل تونس بكل المهاجرين
الغريين النظاميين الذين يعبرون من تونس
للوصول الى الشواطئ الايطاليه وبالتالي
اذا وصل الى
ايطاليا 10,000 مهاجر وبينهم فقط 500
تونسي فان تونس اذا ما ابرمت هذا الاتفاق
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي مقابل كل هذه
المساعدات ستكون مجبره على قبول العشر
الاف مهاجر بطبيعه الحال هذا الاتفاق تمت
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي ولابد الان من
اقناع البرلمان الاوروبي للمصادقه عليه
وان لم يصادق عليه
يكون هناك اي يعني لن تكون له اي منفعه
وهذا اذا ما امضت عليه تونس لان تونس لحد
الان مثلا اليوم الذي تلا زياره الوفد
الاوروبي بمعيه رئيس الوزراء الايطاليه
الكل عنونه تونس تصفع اوروبا وبالتالي
فهموا ان هناك توجه في عدم التمشي في هذا
المسار
وزير الداخليه
في تصريح لها اليوم في التلفزيون يعني
ايطالي يقول هناك يعني ردود فعل خجوله
سماها بخجوله من قبل تونس وبالتالي اظن ان
الفرحه والتصريحات
الاوليه من قبل سواء رئيس الحكومه
الهولندي او رئيس الوزراء الايطاليه التي
اعلنت انها كانت زياره ناجحه اليوم هم
يقولون نحن نظن انها كانت زياره ناجحه
وبالتالي صحيح ان المساعدات الماليه وضخ
ما يقابل من 900 مليون يورو سيكون فقط بعد
ان توقع تونس على هذا الاتفاق في حين انها
وعدت يعني تقديم 100 مليون 100 مليون يورو
للتصدي للهجره ولقبول من يتم ترحيله من من
ايطاليا و150 مليون يورو هي مشاريع مشاريع
يعني قديمه ليست جديده وبالتالي نحن نرى
كيف ان اوروبا حتى تتمكن من الحد من هذه
الهجره الغير نظاميه تريد ان تكون لها
حدود متقدمه وهذه الحدود المتقدمه رات ان
تونس هي التي ستلعب دورا كبيرا في منع
المهاجرين غير النظامين من الوصول الى
ايطاليا وهل هذا الاسلوب يعني بعد اذنك
نعم هل هذا يعني بعد اذنك هل هذا الاسلوب
هنا نسال السيد نوبوتني هل هذا الاسلوب
الاوروبي المعتمد على الاقل الان مع تونس
كما هو واضح بمعنى
اعطيك حزمه مساعدات اساعدك في مفاوضاتك مع
صندوق النقد الدولي ولكن
لتقبل تونس بهذه الشروط هل تعتقد بان هذا
الاسلوب في التعامل وهو اسلوب يعني يوصف
بالابتزاز على الاقل في في تونس هل سيصبح
اسلوب اوروبي يمكن ان يعتمدك مقاربه
اوروبيه عليها اجماع داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي
بعض الامور التي قالها المتحدث السابق من
هناك عده نقاط غير صحيحه او عدم دقه اولا
التسويق الاسبوع الماضي بولندا وهنغاريا
المجرم الذي كان ضد هذه الصفقه اقصد ان
اتعلق اصلاح النظام في اتحاد الاوروبي بعض
الدول امتنعت عن التصويت ثانيا تونس كانت
واحده من اكبر المستقبلين للمساعدات
الماليه للاتحاد الاوروبي الخلال السنوات
15 الماضيه
وفقت حصلت عشره مليارات يورو من حكومات
ثلاثه مليارات من الاتحاد الاوروبي من بين
هذه
وبالتالي غير اطلاقا ما قال له متحدث
السابق بان الاموال لم تسلم بل انها سلمت
الى تونس مع الاسف
لم نشهد نتائج فهذه الامور كانها فقدت في
مكان ما
على الاراضي التونسيه
وهناك الان محاولات جديده
لاعاده العمل بالنظام او بعمليه الاصلاحات
ولا افهم لماذا
ابتزاز المحاوله هي تحقيق اتفاق ذو فائده
متبادله مساعده للاقتصاد التونسي الذي في
حال السيء جيد سيئه جدا لكي يستطيع ان
ينتعش بالدعم من اوروبا وهذا يساعد اتحاد
الاوروبي ان تسيطر على مساله الهجره غير
النظاميه وبالتالي المصلحه متبادله وان
هذا الاسلوب يمكن التحدث مع الدول الاخرى
مثلا مع تركيا
فاول اتفاق بين الاتحاد الاوروبي و28
اعضاء انذاك كانوا في عام 2016
منذ ذلك الوقت
جدد هذا الاتفاق عده مرات لان تركيا تريد
الاعتماد مواصله هذا التعاون او ممكن
نتصور تعاونا مشابها يمكن ان التوصل له مع
تونس التعقيب سريع جدا من صالح المثاني ثم
اذهب للسيده بالملقاسم
اولا هي سلطات والحكومات المتعاقبه على
تونس هي التي اعلنت انها لم تصلها الاموال
التي وعدت بها اوروبا هذا اول شيء ثاني
شيء من امتنع التصويت هي تشيكا وبولندا
وهناك اربع بلدان لا تشيكا بولندا في حين
4 بلدان امتنعت عن التصويت هذا
نشر في اكثر من وسيله الاعلام وبالتالي
عندما نتحدث عن مصالح مشتركه ليست مصالح
مشتركه
سيدي العزيز
ولا يمكن لنا ان نعمل ان نقوم بمقاربه
ايضا مع تركيا تركيا صحيح سنه 2016
المانيا وقعت مع تركيا اتفاق ولكن كان
هناك ملايين من اللاجئين الذين ارادوا
وتدفقوا على اوروبا في حين ان من يصل الى
ايطاليا حتى وان عبر تونس واليوم تريد
يريد الاتحاد الاوروبية أن يعتبرها بلد
امن في حين انها تعيش ازمه القضيه خانقه
هم بضعه الاف مثلا من المفارقه واختم هنا
كيف يمكن ان تعتبر ليبيا يعني
التي تمولها ايطاليا تعطي لها القوارب
لمكافحه النظاميه ويسمح لها الان الى
الدخول الى المياه الاقليميه التونسيه وهي
تتعقب هذه القوارب داخل المياه
الاقليميه التونسيه وتعود بهم الى ليبيا
ولا تعتبرها بلدا امن في حين ان تونس يعني
يريدون ان يعتبروننا
بلدا امن وفيها موانئ امنه وبالتالي يمكن
اعاده عشرات الالاف من الافارقه الى تونس
تونس السيد بن بلقاسم كيف تنظر الى كل هذا
الجدل داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي طبعا
التعديلات التي ادخلت على اتفاق دبلن
الخاص بالهجره يفترض ان يتم اقراره قبل
الانتخابات الاوروبيه في ال 24 حتى يصبح
كاملا ونهائيا
ما المخاوف التي تتوقعها تونس اذا ما
اكتمل المشروع الاوروبي الخاص بالهجره
واللجوء
هو من اكثر المخاوف هو
اجبار تونس او
الضغط على تونس من اجل هذه الاتفاقيات او
ترحيل المهاجرين الغير النظاميين
الموجودين في ايطاليا تحديدا او في اوروبا
الى تونس او عدم احترام المهاجرين غير
النظاميين فهذه المفاوضات يجب ان تقوم
اساسا على احترام الدول لبعضها البعض فعلى
الدول الاوروبيه ان تحترم الدوله التونسيه
ولا يجب ان لا تستغل ظروفها او الازمات
الاقتصاديه التي تمر فيها فهي مجرد فتره
وستمر ولكن لا يجب استغلال هذه الفتره من
اجل جعلها حارسا للحدود وتحميلها مسؤوليه
مسؤوليه الهجره النظاميه كظاهره ككل فهي
مسؤوليه مشتركه فهي تونس قبل كل شيء هي
تعتبر من الدول المصدره للكفاءات التونسيه
نجدها بكثره في الدول الاوروبيه في الدول
الاوروبيه هي تختار المهاجرين مهما كانت
مهاجرين كفاءات علميه او حتى المهاجرين
الغير النظاميين فهو يتم اختيار المهاجرين
حسب مستواهم التعليمي او حسب مكانتهم
الاجتماعيه فلذلك لا يجب على الدول
الاوروبيه ان تقوم بهذا التصرف من اجل
مصلحتها الخاصه ولكن هل هناك تخوف سيده بن
بلقاسم من ان الوضع في تونس قد يصل الى
درجه من السوق اقتصاديا وماليا ما يجعل
تونس امام خيارات شبه معدومه وبالتالي فقد
تجد الحكومه التونسيه نفسها امام قبول
بهذه الصيغه رغم انها مجحفه لانها تحتاج
الى هذه التسعمائه مليون
يورو من من اوروبا تحتاج الى 150 ولو ان
مشاريع قديمه مثل ما قال صالح المتناني
تحتاج الى تعزيز
الترسانه البحريه في في مراقبه الحدود
وبالتالي قد قد تخضع
طبعا هناك مخاوف كبيره وخاصه مثل ما ذكرت
ان تونس تمر بوضع اقتصادي حرج والخوف من
ازدياد الوضع سوء مما يجعلها
تقوم بتوقيع الاتفاقيات او تجد نفسها تخضع
لهذه الاتفاقيات لذلك يجب على الدول
الافريقيه الاخرى او دول المغرب العربي او
الدول التي تصدر كذلك المهاجرين الغير
نظامين عن طريق تونس عند ان تقوم بان
تتضافر الجهود من اجل مساعده الدوله
التونسيه وعدم ايقاعها في هذا الفخ وعدم
تحملها المسؤوليه المهاجرين النظاميين
لوحدها لذلك يجب ان تتضافر جميع الدول
الاخرى من اجل عدم ايقاع تونس في هذا الفخ
وجعلها حارس الحدود الاوروبي
في نهايه البرنامج كالعاده نقوم بهذه
الجوله بين ضيوفنا سنبدا بضيفنا في
بروكسال ثم نعود الى السيده بن جبل القاسم
وننتهي مع صالح المثناني ابدا بضيفنا
السيد نوفوتني اساله عن توقعاته او
السيناريوهات التي يراها في تعامل اوروبا
مع الضفه الجنوبيه للمتوسط في قضيه الهجره
في الفتره المقبله
استطيع ان اقدم لكم سيناروين اثنين
متطرفين لكل جانب من جانب الموضوع
ربما اكون الحل الصحيح وفي الوسط
الطرف الاول او الوضع في التونسي استاد
السوءا اقتصاديا وسياسيا
وهناك الكثير من المهاجرين تونسيين وغير
تونسيين سيحاولون التوجه الى اتحاد
الاوروبي والكثير منهم سيغرقوا في الطريق
في البحر
ومع عدم وجود اي اتفاق بين تونس واوروبا
ومن الطرف الاخر المعارض او البعيد
كاسيناريو ان يكون هناك التعاون بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتونس ويستمر هذا
التعاون بشكل مثمر وتونس
تتبنى وتقوم بتنفيذ الاصلاحات الضروريه
المساعدات من
الاتحاد الاوروبي وصندوق النقد الدولي
وهذا وهذا سيساهم في قطع الطريق الهجره
غير النظاميه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي ثم
واعاده الذين يحاولون ان يصلوا الى
اختاروا لوصول الى اوروبا واذا هذا هما
سيناريوهين منفصلين احدهما سيء جدا الاخر
جيد جدا وعامل اننا كنا الى جانب
السيناريو الثاني فاذا نسرين بالبلقاسم
هو بالنسبه
للازمه التي نمر بها حاليا لقد مرت على
تونس العديد من الازمات ولكن
دائما تتجاوز هذه المشاكل وتوقعاتي ستكون
ايجابيه اننا سنتجاوز هذه الاشكاليه وتكون
باخف الاضرار وربما نصل الى اتفاقيات التي
تتماشى
وتحترم مهما كان يعني الدوله التونسيه او
الدول الاوروبيه وايطاليا تحديدا هل يمكن
لتونس ان تكون لها خيارات الى حد ما
معقوله بمعنى انها لا تمانع في التعاون مع
اوروبا على الاقل من حيث الحصول على زوارق
ومعدات لمراقبه الحدود ولكن على ان لا تصل
الامور الى حد مثلا قبول عائدين او
مطرودين من من اوروبا للعوده الى تونس
التي انطلقوا منها
طبعا هو التعاون دائما يكون من الاشياء
الايجابيه ويكون التعاون بطريقه سلميه
وخاصه في احترام الحقوق الانسان واحترام
المهاجرين
واعتبارهم كمواطنين يتمتعون بحريه التنقل
وفي حد ذاته حتى بالنسبه للدول الاوروبيه
وعندما يكون الاتفاق يحترم كل كلاء
الدولتين فيجب ان يكون ذلك هو الموجود
توقعاتك سيد صالح المثماني
او سيناريوهاتك
[موسيقى]
اوروبا ايضا هي في حاجه لهؤلاء اللاجئين
كيدعاون وايضا حتى يتمكنوا من دفع جرايات
المتقاعدين الايطاليين ونحن نعلم ان هذه
القاره يعني قد اصبحت قاره معظمها يعني
شيوخ وفي حاجه الى دماء جديده ويمكن
لهؤلاء المهاجرين يعني المساعده في عدم
انهيار هذه القاره العجوز هل جمهور ميلوني
اليميني يمكن ان يشكل اداه ضغط عليها وعلى
حكومتها للمضي قدما في هذا التوجه سواء مع
تونس او مع غيرها
لا اعتقد لان المقاربه الان بدات تختلف
مثلا بدانا نسمع لاول مره عن امكانيه يعني
استقبال عمال يعني كفؤ من تونس
واعاده يعني
انه الحصص مثلا لهذه السنه اكثر من 82 الف
عامل سيفودون الى ايطاليا وقد تحدث وزير
الخارجيه الايطالي
ان في السنوات الخمس القادمه
يستقبلون ما يقارب 500 الف عامل يعني من
بلدان عده واتصور ان هذه المقاربه الاكثر
يعني
التي يمكن ان تساعد الطرفين الضيف من
بروكسل يقول يعني هذا الاتفاق يمكن ان
يساعد البلدين سواء الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتونس انا ارى ان افضل اتفاق هو ان يعني
تفاوض تونس
لمزيد من العمال الذين يقدمون بطريقه
القانونيه وان يغيروا ايضا نظام التاشيره
نحن نعلم ان هناك العديد من الشباب ومنطلب
التونسيين وغير التونسيين الذين لا
يستطيعون اليوم ان يقدموا لتاشيره وهذا ما
يدفع بالعديد من الشباب الى محاوله الهجره
الى اوروبا بطريقه غير نظميه شكرا لك صالح
المثناني من روما شكرا ايضا لضيفتنا من
تونس
نسرين بالبلقاسم ولي ضيفنا من بروكسيل
بهذا نصل للمشاهدينا الكرام الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله موعدنا يتجدد
باذن الله الاسبوع المقبل وسناريوهات جديد
في امان الله
[موسيقى]